All right. 20, 26% perspective. Now in myeloma, we have a lot of riches, gray and blue, gray,
newly diagnosed blue and relapse refractory. We have so many drugs to use, but really is
the question is, is, you know, what sequence and in what combinations do we use them? Right.
And that's what I'm going to talk about. But the first thing is we had our first meeting a few
months ago in Miami, the cure meeting. It's the first time the C word has actually been used in
myeloma. And this was Sundar basically used it in EHA and said cure 10 times during his discussion
in EHA after the results, the five years results were still to sell. So we had a meeting. We now
have a definition. Now we got to find out how we can get more people there. Right. We talk about
newly diagnosed myeloma. There's many flavors of nearly newly diagnosed myeloma. That's why
it's multiple myeloma, right? Age, frailty, performance status, what they're, what
their genetics look like. Do they have EMD, et cetera. And we have to take all of these data
points and decide what we're going to give them. But I will say, you know, two things, one risk,
the risk classification, we changed our risk classification. You'll hear more about that
at this meeting. All right. If we take out some from the old standard risk, we take out some of
what we think are now are high risk. The old standard risk curve gets better. And on the
right, if we take out the old high risk, we take out some of the people that truly maybe did
not have high risk. You see the new high risk really doesn't do well. That's our unmet need.
Right. But does it really matter? Right. We have the Perseus study and you can see in the bottom,
the PFS curve from the Perseus study in the best fit curve is telling us that Dara VRD PFS is 205
months. What that's 17 years, right? It is a 65 year olds. What is their average lifespan?
Right. It's in their eighties. That one line gets them
to their average lifespan. That's amazing. What about the Cepheus trial? The same thing,
the best fit curve gets Dara VRD without transplant at a hundred months, right? These are 75 year olds.
This is going seven years. This is getting them to their, their standard with one line of therapy,
but can we do better? Right. And we'll talk about that in a minute. So first role of transplant is
transplant on life support. I have to, I, I, sorry, I have to say it's hard for me to say
that in front of Sergio. Because Sergio is my mentor. He got me into myeloma. That guy right
there got me into myeloma. I was a leukemia doc when I was really young, when I had dark hair.
Okay. But the determination trial taught us that transplant is important for high risk. And in fact,
we have three really good high risk trials, the optimum trial, the IFM trial, and the concept
trial that shows that transplant in four or five drug induction, three or four drug consolidation,
and long-term two or three drugs with high risk is important. That's how we treat high risk,
but it's still our, our, you know, our worst nightmare now life support. Here's where the
life support comes in. Sorry, Joe, sir, Sergio. And that is Midas, the Midas trial, six cycles of
ESA KRD. Those are people that did not actually achieve MRD negativity were randomized to two
transplant versus one transplant. Those that did get MRD negative, got just
standard therapy, randomized to standard therapy or a single transplant and standard consolidation
and then maintenance-based therapy. Now, so the long and skinny of that is that basically it
didn't matter if you got a transplant or not an early timeframe at this point in time. And it
didn't matter if you got two or one transplant, two transplants is dead. Alrighty. Most of us
here are in the U S so that's, you know, what we usually do, but for those out of the U S that are
still using two transplants, I think it is dead. I think
life, I think it didn't CPR didn't work. It was over. Okay. So I will tell you that now,
even in the U S the cobalt trial from Dr. Usmani and Sarah looking at basically,
can we basically challenge autologous transplant? This is a Bispecific versus autologous transplant
as consolidation after induction based therapy, but every group around the world is doing such a study.
This is a French study. And this French study looks at basically those that are MRD negative,
the good group of just getting tech dare series, tech Len, the bad group, the ones that are MRD
positive after induction. This is the four drug Dara VRD, Dutch and tech towel.
Okay. We also have data that's coming from transplant from upfront. This was done by
Juan do in Shanghai, looking at the BCMA CD 19 car. And suffice it to say, looking at frontline therapy
and some people that were transplant eligible. And some of that were transplant eligible at 36
months follow-up, the overall survival of the PFS is around 90%, pretty amazing. We'll see how that
goes in the next level, but what we're really waiting for, right? Is CAR-T five and CAR-T six,
transplant ineligible and transplant eligible and looking at randomized trials of does car work in
the transplant ineligible compared to standard lend maintenance. And does it work in the
transplant eligible versus autologous transplant?
I have a lot of wine bent bet on this. Okay. Last seconds. Cause of my time is taking down
the origa trial. Should we just use one drug of for maintenance therapy? No, we shouldn't. Okay. I'm
trying to be controversial if you guys don't understand. And that's because on the left,
you see more green on the left and the right dub two is always better than one in multiple myeloma.
But is that always true? Right? If we look at now the majestic four study, the early data, trying to
look at looking at a.
Bispecific for maintenance-based therapy, whether you use Bispecific alone, Bispecific plus rev
the big, the hundred percent is all MRD negativity after six or 12 months. These drugs are amazing,
right? They're going front line and here's the PFS curve. Let me show you that less, maybe more.
This is the linker MM four study. Okay. Just using limbo cell to map, no other drug induction,
transplant eligible can get a transplant transplant ineligible. Just
continues on with one drug. Most of these transplant eligible patients are not going
to get transplant in my mind, high overall response rates, high CRS early on in everybody.
The majority of patients are reaching MRD negativity. What about tech Lil just using
tech Dara frontline? What, what kind of curve is this? When do we see curves like this? Right?
With that, I think I'm going to drop the mic and I'll move on to the next speaker. Thank you.